réunion sur le coït 19 à lille
déambulation dans les rues de la
capitale des flandres discussions avec
des couturières à roubaix jean castex
démultiplie un mois après sa nomination
pour tenter d'imposer sa patte à
matignon plus de dialogue et de
concertation mais aussi une fermeté
assumer concernant les sujets régaliens
et notamment le volet sécuritaire
priorité du moment la lutte contre le
corona virus n'est pas en reste
la menace d'euros confirmant est prise
au sérieux par le premier ministre qui
réaffirme sa détermination face au virus
il faut que nous comprenions toutes et
tous que l'objectif est simple nous
protéger contre ce virus surtout sans
faire arrêter la vie la vie économique
et la vie sociale c'est à dire un
évitant la perspective d'un recompte
finement généralisée tel est en tout cas
l'objectif du gouvernement
le début de mandat de jean castex est
plombée par les accusations de viol qui
vit son ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin et la nomination
controversée et eric dupond-moretti au
ministère de la justice
malgré les polémiques le premier
ministre se montre solidaire de son
gouvernement
je suis aujourd'hui accompagné de gérald
darmanin
ministre de l'intérieur nommé sur ma
proposition par le président ben ali et
qui bénéficie de toute notre confiance
pour exercer cette haute fonction la
présence à mes côtés du garde des sceaux
dans la nomination a été entouré de
nombreux commentaires en réalité incarne
cette volonté du président de la
république et de moi même de faire de ce
sujet une priorité un style qui se veut
moins technocratique que son
prédécesseur mais qui est loin de faire
l'unanimité
l'opposition ne s'est pas fait prier
pour fustiger son discours de politique
générale le 13 juillet dernier
c'est assez pénible à supporter les mots
pouces entre les arbres et les arbres
entre les mots il est là il parle à deux
à l'heure pour dire des banalités
alors soit on prend mal et on dit mais
il se moque de nous soit on se dit c'est
le maximum dont il est capable
ce n'est pas un bon moment de démocratie
parlementaire à écouter le premier
ministre ce matin à la séance de
questions au gouvernement
je constate qu'il a pour mission de nous
endormir si les derniers sondages semble
lui être favorable la crise sanitaire
pourrait ébranler le capital sympathie
de l'ancien maire de prades
confronté à la plus grande crise
économique depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale le premier ministre devra
affronter une rentrée potentiellement
explosive sur le plan social et
économique
un véritable baptême du feu pour celui
qui reste encore un inconnu pour une
grande partie des français